We not necessarily involved in this
kind of judgement ourselves,
but we recognize the phenomenon
in our society well enough.
The more someone earn, the more
likely to be admired by strangers
and perceived as interesting and exciting.
Respect appears all too often to be directly
awarded according to earnings.
And in a related move, if you don't have
much economic endorsement,
it can be hard for your character
or views to be taken seriously.
It's not a mystery that this
relationship got established.
because there is so many conspicuous cases
where we find genuine link between talent,
effort, skill, contribution, and income.
The most impressive example
involves brilliant surgeons,
the authors of Matilda and Harry Potter,
or the team behind the development of graphene.
All these geniuses have a lot of talent,
they made a lot of money,
and their contribution are terrific.
They make a connections between high income and virtue seems right and natural.
But, turn to the pages of economics
textbooks, and a very different
far less emotive account wages emerges.
Economic states that : the wages are determined
not by the social contribution,
but by number of people able
and willing to do a given job
that others won't done.
If there's a lot of people able to complete the task
you won't need to offer very much
money to get their labor.
And if very few people able to do the job,
you'll have to pay a lot more.
But note that there's no room to judge
the worth of the work being done.
The determined of wages is just
the strength of demand in relation to supply
Taken in one direction,
this explains the high salary of hit man.
A person who can,
for the most exact thing and difficult missions
where the target posses private guards and is
protected by triple layer security glass
extract an early seven-figure sum.
Simply because almost no one on earth
is capable of carrying out such a complex maneuver.
Taken in other direction, the same theory of wages,
explains the salary of modern hospice nurse.
Charged with accompanying people
through their last days,
a task as meaningful as one could imagine,
yet whose salary is
a tiny fraction of the murderous stipend.
In neither case do the wages have any
connection to the contributions being made.
It simply has to do with
how many people are capable of carrying
out a task,
and how much demand there is for it.
It is so happens in our society
some really wonderful quality like
consideration, sympathy, and hard work
are actually rather widespread,
which has deeply paradoxical consequence.
Yo can employ someone
with astonishing qualities
and get away with offering them
pretty much nothing at all.
The whole economic system
can seem entirely lacking in justice.
And our minds rebel against the gross
violation of the principles of fairness.
It's normal if we should
scan the horizon
in the hope of finding some
answers that can lessen the pain.
In the history of the West,
there've been two huge
intellectual attempts to resolve
the impressions of injustice
around wages.
The first is: Christianity.
A doctrine which has insisted
that a person's worth
is to be determined in an entirely
different sense to the financial.
After death, the person's soul
will be weighed by God.
and his or her true merits
perfectly rewarded for eternity.
Wages can't change here on earth,
but the meaning of the wage will
in the eyes of Christianity
be altered, and the humiliation
of poverty should
hence lose some of it's bitter sting.
The other huge attempt to introduce
justice was Marxism.
Karl Marx's work argued for a
new world in which
workers would, for the the first time,
rewarded according to the worth
of their contributions to society.
So down would go; the wages of a hit men,
casino owners, mining tycoons.
And up go the wages of the nurse,
and the farmer.
Communism would return justice
to income.
In their own day, these seemed like a
very impressive solutions.
Yet for different reasons,
they're not in any way things
we can now put our hopes on.
The current economic order is pretty
firmly established and not about to change
any time soon.
But the hopes remain for some
way of dealing with the disjuncture
between wages and contributions.
It may be an odd place to look,
but the most immediately
usable solution to the situation
may lie in a really unexpected place;
the walls of an upper gallery
in the Wallace Collection
in London's Manchester Square.
Home to a small painting called,
The Lace Maker,
by a little-known German artist
called Casper Netscher,
who painted it in 1664.
We've caught the Lace Maker in what
looks like a quiet mid-afternoon.
She's concentrating on a difficult task
carefully threading her needle.
It would take her five hours just
to make one square centimeter.
Her eye's will tire, she'll make
something dazzling and moving,
an externalization of the best sides of her nature.
And yet, her reward for the exquisite
craftmanship will be a few pennies at best.
Lace making was a major industry for
women in 17th and 18th century.
But as it happens, it was also one of the
lowest paid for a stubborn unbudgable
reason we coming now to understand.
Lots of people could do this work.
Interestingly, many artists were drawn
to paint lace maker at their task.
The artists had no hopes of
reforming how lace makers got paid,
but hey had the ambition to change
the lives of lace makers nevertheless
They wanted to use art to alter
the status of these lace maker
by directing viewers to the
intelligence and dignity
of the craft of  lace making.
They hope to redeem the social standing
of this economically slighted class.
What the artist were doing with lace makers
a general capacity of art
to redraw what we think as prestigious
and to return proper appreciation
for what certain people.
Especially those deemed marginal
by the dominant social hierarchy
are and do.
Sadly, for all the status we accorded,
art is actually a pretty small thing in the world.
But the move that art has made,
needs to, and can be redeployed
on a much larger scale
Art is a mechanism for appreciation.
which is particularly adept at a close
study in which an individual might be deserving
of tenderness, sympathy and admiration;
and yet neglected by the wider world.
The goal of art is to increase the amount of dense
and accurate information about people's jobs.
So we can stop using mere wages
as our measuring rods.
Once we get to know people well,
in art or otherwise,the state of their bank balance
invariably declines a little.
And what they're really bringing
to their task starts to emerge
along with the fairer way of
distributing honor and respect.